so I recently spoke with Dr Brandon
Berry about his work using the tool
mitochondria on here I will explain how
it works in ourselves we have organelles
you have likely heard of one called
mitochondria
primarily these organelles are
responsible for the generation of ATP
the way ATP is generated is through the
generation of a proton motor Force
essentially a high concentration of
protons hydrogen ions in the space
between the membranes of this organelle
when these protons move down their
concentration gradient out of this
inter-membrane space
they go through a protein called ATP
synthase the movement of protons through
this protein facilitates a generation of
ATP the energy source of the cell
mitochondria on is a tool that also
moves protons across this membrane but
it can only do this in the presence of a
cofactor or trans retinal and lights
in this paper Brandon activated this
tool using Glides during adulthood of
the worms
and so this helped to maintain the
proton motor Force
he showed that by maintaining this
proton motor force it extended the
lifespan of the worms
listen to our full conversation here